[Música]
hola buenas noches cómo están
como esta en el que siempre quise decir
eso
mi nombre es nicolás martínez y soy
biólogo entomólogo soy biólogo estudio
insectos unos bichos que son súper
interesantes para mí son
hermosísimos pero
sospecho que no sé si ustedes piensan lo
mismo entonces yo les quería preguntar
si ven a la pantalla
cuando yo les hablo de insectos ustedes
con cuál de estas reacciones se
identifican con ésta
con esta con la segunda que me dicen la
segunda no
y la verdad es que si yo les pregunto
van a decirme que los bichos son
asquerosos que son feos que hay que
matarlos y que ninguno de ustedes
tendría remordimientos de pisar pisar
cualquier cierto
pero lo cierto es que los insectos son
los organismos más comunes del planeta y
cerca de un millón de especies
descriptas
y están en el planeta hace 300 millones
de años o sea que están antes que
nosotros y probablemente estén después
que nosotros
y los insectos viven en el suelo viven
debajo del suelo viven sobre otros
animales
y tienen un montón de formas de vida hay
insectos que se alimentan de cadáveres
de excremento de madera de sangre de
néctar de plantas en fin un montón de
adaptaciones que hacen de los insectos
colonizadores
exitosísimos de casi cualquier tipo de
ambiente
y qué pasaría sin insectos el
apocalipsis
los insectos son indispensables para el
funcionamiento de todos los ecosistemas
entonces sin insectos se desencadenarían
un montón de reacciones que
culminarían en el colapso del mundo así
como lo conocemos hoy en día
y porque son importantes y una de las
funciones que cumplen los insectos por
ejemplo es la de su papel como the tree
tea borox qué quiere decir esto que
pueden descomponer la materia orgánica
de plantas y animales y liberar
nutrientes que son esenciales para
nuestra vida como el nitrógeno que está
presente en el adn en los aminoácidos
que forman proteínas
para darles un ejemplo no sé si están
familiarizados con los escarabajos
estercoleros
que son estos escarabajos que se
alimentan de excrementos y que forman
unas unas pelotas muy grandes
que las transportan con las patas
traseras hacia su nido ahí lo entierran
y entonces facilitan la descomposición
de esta materia fecal en nutrientes que
pueden ser aprovechados por las plantas
y por el resto de los animales a lo
largo de las cadenas tróficas
imagínense por ejemplo pensando en las
vacas que se alimentan de pasto
imagínense si no habría de estos
escarabajos entonces la materia fecal se
acumularía de tal forma que la vaca no
se alimentarían de los pastos entonces
aportan bastante para
evitar la acumulación excesiva del
excremento
también los insectos están presentes en
todas las cadenas tróficas qué quiere
decir que hay muchos animales que se
alimentan de insectos y los insectos se
alimentan de muchísimos animales y
plantas entonces si no existen los
insectos el flujo de energía sería
muchísimo menor
también los insectos son importantes
como agentes de control biológico qué
quiere decir esto que los podemos usar o
nos pueden ayudar a controlar las
poblaciones de aquellos organismos que
pueden ser perjudiciales para nosotros
porque se los comen o por ejemplo el
caso de una avispa
que inocula los huevos en otra visita
que se alimenta de pinos
entonces de esta manera
mata a este a este organismo que es
perjudicial para nosotros porque los
pinos tienen su valor económico en
madera
entonces son buenos como controladores
de plagas también pues son
polinizadores de la mayoría de las
plantas con flores es decir de las
plantas que nos proveen el alimento
como frutos secos como legumbres como
frutas como verduras de hoja y cuando
nosotros pensamos en polinizadores
pensamos en las abejas cierto pero
también hay un montón de otros insectos
polinizadores como escarabajos como
polillas como mariposas como moscas
pero en este mundo capitalista en el que
nos toca vivir
por ahí esto no tiene tanto impacto como
si yo les hablo de los aportes del
beneficio económico que traen los
insectos hace algunos años unos
investigadores intentaron estimar cuál
es el beneficio económico de los
insectos en millones de dólares y
llegaron a la cuenta que aportan unos 60
mil millones millones de dólares sólo en
eeuu así que imagínense lo importante
que son
también los insectos nos pueden dar
información de la calidad de los
ambientes por ejemplo
hay unos escarabajos acuáticos que se
llaman enemigos que nos pueden dar mucha
información de la calidad de agua y son
unos bichos realmente son los más
hermosos y casualmente son con los que
yo trabajo solo casualidad
estos bichitos
si ustedes ven ahí a la derecha están
los gusanitos que son las larvas y a la
izquierda están los adultos las larvas
viven en el agua
y en el último estadio cuando crecen
salen del agua hacen con un capullo una
pupa como como puede ser la de las
mariposas y después
de ese capullo emerge el adulto y el
adulto otra vez se mete al agua y no
sale nunca más
y estos estos insectos viven en arroyos
y ríos y dependen mucho del oxígeno
quiere decir que si nosotros vemos de
estos escarabajos que son muy chiquitos
si hay muchos podemos decir que esa
calidad es buena de ese arroyo de ese
río y también lo que tienen interesante
es que ahí pueden ver que en el vientre
en la panza tienen con unos pelitos que
ahí se ven como como un terciopelo
dorado ese perrito se llama tormento y
esos pelitos no se mojan entonces tienen
la capacidad de retener una burbuja de
aire entonces el insecto se respira a
través de esa burbuja y no hace falta
que salga del agua a tomar aire sino que
con eso le alcanza para
desarrollar su vida en el agua
y esos pelitos son muy sensibles a
contaminantes como detergentes o sólidos
en suspensión
entonces si hay poquito de estos bichos
nosotros podemos sospechar que la
calidad de agua no nos daba mucha
información de que esa calidad de agua
no es buena
pero qué es lo que está pasando
han visto este meme en facebook o en
alguna otra red social sí bueno ahí
vemos hay un señor que hace 20 años
atrás
tenía el parabrisas del auto lleno lleno
de insectos aplastados y 20 años después
no y él estaba contento pero qué pasa
e investigadores han recopilado
información que es lo que está pasando
con las poblaciones de insectos en los
últimos 20 años y se han dado cuenta que
hay una baja muy importante en el número
de los insectos y esto se puede ver a
que se han incrementado muchísimo a lo
largo de los años las áreas destinadas a
urbanización agricultura ha aumentado la
contaminación y esto trae como
consecuencia la degradación del hábitat
en especial para los insectos entonces
sus números han bajado notablemente
y cuáles son las consecuencias bueno
como como habíamos visto la producción
de productos agrícolas bajarían más o
menos un tercio que es un montón se
extinguirían un montón de aves mamíferos
ips reptiles que se alimentan casi
exclusivamente de insectos
como vimos el prejuicio económico sería
devastador se alteraría en un montón de
procesos químicos
entonces realmente el mundo tal cual
como lo conocemos dejaría de existir
entonces yo quería compartir con ustedes
mi pasión por los insectos y también
transmitirles lo importante que son
y sembrar una semillita porque los
insectos
históricamente no han sido tenidos en
cuenta en planes de manejo y por ahí
generamos conciencia entre nosotros y
por ahí está estos pensamientos llegan a
algún actor que tome decisiones en la
política o en planes de manejo entonces
después de haber escuchado esta charla
que me pueden decir a ver con cuál
reacción se se identifican ahora
con esto cuántos poquitos
con esta
con esta porque la segunda
vio en mí de que se quede correcto pero
bueno
muchísimas gracias estoy muy contento de
estar acá muchas gracias